gift wissenschaftlich schönreden ist
inzwischen ein regelrechter beruf habe
ich gelernt professor matthias matschke
zb ist einer der gefragtesten deutschen
honorarprofessoren das heißt er sagt
gegen honorar alles was sie wollen das
ist richtig herr werke übrigens eine
ganz hervorragende sendung heute
herr professor
professor matschke über diese art
wissenschaft ist eine schande
hier kommen jetzt mal originalzitate aus
einem gt newsletter da heißt es wörtlich
zitieren
feinstaubpartikel und stickoxide gehen
wegen der modernen abgasreinigung auf
ein nahezu homöopathisches niveau zurück
quasi gesunde abgase oder hier noch
besser
man könnte fast sagen dass ein moderner
diesel in vielen situationen sozusagen
die luft reinigt
geht's noch wieso beweisen sie erst mal
das gegenteil
dieselabgase sind ein homöopathisches
medikament wenn ich zum beispiel
probleme mit den atemwegen habe nehme
ich gerne mal ein paar von den neuen vw
globuli aus gepresstem feinstaub in den
geschmacksrichtungen apfel diesel und
zimt bluemotion schön meine bezahlten
forschungen beweisen eindeutig nichts an
deutschen diesel ist in irgendeiner
weise ungesund wir haben das alles
ausprobiert hier diesen probanden zb ja
wir mussten einen menschen nehmen an dem
tag hatten die affen frei diesen
probanden haben wir mal mit einem
modernen euro 6 diesel überfahren und
wie sie sehen selbst überfahren werden
ist annähernd nicht annähernd so
ungesund wie das die ganzen umwelt
spannung immer behauptet
wir haben das noch 78 mal gemacht und
was soll ich sagen
der proband hat seitdem keine
rückenschmerzen mehr toll wie
weggeblasen
jetzt kommen sie herr welke als über
diese messwerte in vielen deutschen
städten sind eine katastrophe da muss
doch irgendwas passieren ja es passiert
ja auch was in essen zum beispiel da
gibt es ein problem straße wo ist
tatsächlich nicht so leicht ist mit dem
nach wir heißen dass hier atmen anwohner
natürlich stinkesauer
aber selbst da zeichnet sich jetzt eine
geniale lösung ab auf seite 2 der
rahmenplanung steht ja wir sind leider
nicht in der lage die belastung durch
die autos zu senken
die lösung wie man uns anbietet nach
immer nur 32 jahre ignoriert hat man
möchte unsere häuser abreißen die stadt
essen verteidigt ihren plan mit dem
abriss der häuser würden sich die
belüftungs bedingungen verbessern
viel bessere belüftung der eigentliche
feind sind nämlich nicht die autos das
sind die häuser wir müssen einfach viel
mehr häuser in den städten abreißen und
jetzt mal ehrlich ich weiß es ist
unpopulär aber sowas wie bielefeld
braucht man das überhaupt oder mannheim
waren sie damals geht gar nichts
super idee wir reißen einfach alle
deutschen städte hab ja sie lachen aber
für den verkehr wäre das super hier
da müssen wir wieder hin köln 14
das war eine belüftung die alten leute
sterben heute noch professor matthias
manche gemeinden haben und haben
[Applaus]